[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and Speaker of amazing facts
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact without question the
Voyager 1 and 2 spacecraft are among the
most successful scientific expeditions
in history first launched in 1977 and
designed to last about 5 years they are
both still communicating with earth 40
years later the voyagers gave us some of
our first close-up photos of the great
planets in the furthest reaches of our
solar system they explored Jupiter
Saturn Uranus Neptune as well as a
number of other moons and asteroids just
in case they encounter intelligent life
both Voyager 1 and 2 spacecraft are
carrying with him a gold record with
photos and drawings spoken greetings in
many languages music and earth sounds
however the extraterrestrials will have
to figure out how to build a record
player to hear it both of the Voyager
craft have now left our solar system and
they're traveling through interstellar
space at more than 38,000 miles an hour
powered by a radioisotope thermoelectric
generator
Voyager 1 may keep exploring space for
another 10 to 20 years before its power
runs out because there are over 13
billion miles from Earth it takes over
16 hours for scientists received to
receive data from the probe on the other
hand the Bible says that your prayers
reach heaven instantly stay where those
friends were going to learn more on this
edition of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at one
eight hundred
says that's one eight hundred four sixty
three seventy to ninety seven now let's
join our host pastor Doug Batchelor
welcome listening friends if you have a
Bible question that's what this program
is all about just pick up your phone we
have lines wide open right now excellent
opportunity to get your call on
tonight's program that number once again
800 god says you got a pencil eight
hundred four six three seven two ninety
seven yes we are alive we think this is
the best format and medium for radio we
don't talk about romance or finance
unless it's biblical finance but we talk
about the Word of God and any questions
about living the Christian life lines
are open here's the number once more
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven i'm doug batchelor pastor
ross has the night off
and we're gonna start the program with
the word of Prayer
loving Lord we just thank you that we
can know that when we talk to you you
hear us instantly it's faster than the
speed of sound or the speed of light
it's the speed of Prayer and lord I pray
that you will just look down right now
on this broadcast this evening and bless
with your spirit we pray that the
questions that are asked and the answers
that are given are all in harmony with
the word of truth and we pray these
things in Jesus name Amen you know we
started out at the beginning of the
program talking about prayer I don't
remind you we do have lines open one
more time 800 God says that's 800 for
six three seven two nine seven brings
your question into the radio program
tonight 804 63 72 97 we spoke at the
beginning about this incredible journey
of the Voyager 1 and the Voyager 2
spacecraft and it really is pretty
amazing when you think that there's
something that man is
made now that has gone beyond the solar
system it's escaped the gravitational
pull of the Sun and it can you know
conceivably go on for millions of years
at the speed its traveling before it'll
really collide with anything and that
we're still communicating with that
device that is outside of our solar
system and it was built with technology
that we would laugh at now from 1977
basically they're powered by little mini
nuclear reactors when I heard that the
battery of the Voyager spacecrafts are
still operating I thought why I'd like
some of those batteries in my car and my
other devices but as fast as those
things are traveling your prayers travel
much faster you know the Bible tells us
even before we call he will answer now
it's important to pray but Jesus tells
us he knows what things we have Nia
even before we pray one time the
disciples saw Jesus rising from prayer
and he was walking away and they could
see that his face was a glowing after
communion with his father and in awe
they said to Jesus teach us to pray now
you know how Jesus responded he gave
them what we commonly think of as the
Lord's Prayer and you find that in both
the Gospel of Matthew and the Gospel of
Luke in Matthews version it says our
Father and but first of all Jesus says
in this manner prayed and certainly not
wrong to repeat the Lord's Prayer but he
didn't say just repeat this prayer he
said pray in this manner so the Lord's
Prayer is really an outline for our
prayers beginning by addressing God the
Father reverently hallowed be thy name
your kingdom come
keeping the big picture of our work in
this world to share his kingdom your
will be done now there's seven petitions
in the Lord's Prayer three of those
petitions are to God the other four
petitions deal with our relationship
with our fellow man then it says give us
this day our daily bread forgive us our
debts as we forgive our debtors and do
not lead us into temptation but deliver
us from the
some of you listening may remember that
just a week or so ago the Pope said that
he thinks that the translation of the
Lord's Prayer and at least Italian
English and many other languages is not
very accurate where it says lead us not
into temptation makes it sound like God
once the temp doesn't we have to beg him
not to it actually is saying lead us
away from our natural leaning to
temptation and then of course deliver us
from the evil one for yours is the
kingdom and the power and the glory
forever
the Lord's Prayer is a beautiful pattern
for prayer and there's a lot we can
learn about God and our needs in this
prayer now I've written a book that I'm
gonna share with anybody that calls and
asks for tonight and it's a book called
the beautiful secrets of prayer and if
you'd like to get a copy of that book
you just tell them that you want my book
on prayer they'll be happy to send that
to you and it will I believe strengthen
your faith and just increase deepen your
relationship with the Lord if you call
the resource number asked for the book
teach us to pray and here's a number
again this is for the book eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
this is for the resource 8:30 five six
seven four seven that's toll-free 800
and if you want to call in with your
questions we still have plenty of lines
open 800 God says 800 four six three
seven two 97 and with that we're gonna
go to the phones and I'm going to be
talking to somebody by the name of
anonymous hello you're on the air with
Bible answers live can you hear me let
me try that again
anonymous are you on the air are you
there hello Bible answers live can you
hear me yeah I hear you in the
background you're on the air with Bible
answers live hello you might have your
mute button on
are you on the air okay well I'm gonna
have to go to another caller looks like
so we're gonna talk next to put that on
hold and I talked to Rosarita is that
right no that I'm sorry and welcome your
own Bible answers life hi Aunt Esther
bachelor I wanted to know about Ezekiel
chapter 37 okay
oh you I can't read the whole thing any
I'm sorry go ahead
what verses verse 19 is that information
about David a metaphor or an expected
future event all right let me get there
and I'll read it for everybody most of
our listeners are riding in the car but
let's see here Ezekiel chapter 37 you
said verse 19 say to them thus says the
Lord God surely I will take the stick of
Joseph which is in the hand of Ephraim
and and the tribes of Israel his
companions and I will join them with
them with it with the stick of Judah and
make them one stick and wherever they
have gone and they shall no longer be
two nations nor shall they ever be
divided into two kingdoms again is that
the verse you want and they shall not
defile themselves any more with their
idols nor their detestable things nor
with any of their transgressions but
I'll deliver them from all their
dwelling places in which I bring them
and that it says my servant David shall
be king over them is that the part you
wondering about yeah that a metaphor or
a future event it is a metaphor
now even in heaven you know David will
be resurrected David's going to be in
heaven but Jesus was always the one that
David looked to as his Lord even David
prophesied and said My Lord said unto
the Lord let me put your enemies beneath
your footstool David always understood
that the Messiah would be the ultimate
king of Israel
Jesus is referred to as the son of David
when and it says I will give you the
throne of your father David a prophecy
about Jesus
when the blind men came and asked for
healing they said son of David have
mercy on me and so all the Jews
understood that the Messiah would be
from the line of David and so when it
says David my servant will be king over
them it means a descendent from the
house of David now let me explain why it
says all that you notice it talked about
Joseph and Judah talked about these two
sticks I'll join them together after the
time of Solomon the nation of Judah
where David reigned Judah Benjamin Levi
they were separated from the Northern
Kingdom there was a civil war and
because of this civil war they were
separated right up until the Babylonian
captivity and the northern kingdom never
recognized the sons of David as king but
it's telling us in heaven they'll no
longer be two nations but they're once
again be a United people that's talking
here about spiritual Israel as well as
anything and they'll be one nation so it
isn't a metaphor for Jesus Jesus in the
book of Revelation is called the the son
of David the the throne and the keys of
David the father are given to Jesus okay
praise their explanation and thank you
very much master bath designer god bless
you thank you very much hey I appreciate
your call all right we're gonna try a
line number one now all right doc are
you on the air yes I am hi thank you and
your call tonight yes it has to do with
the food laws this time of year there a
lot of get-togethers and a lot of stuff
laid out on the table tonight a room saw
something I've never seen before a
deviled egg with a crispy piece of bacon
sticking out of it yeah I haven't read
Leviticus I know that pork and shellfish
and and knowing something about biology
that all these animals are scavengers
and if it was toxic back then it stands
to reason to mean it is toxic now and
when I try to bring this Leviticus up
they say France and say that that had to
do with the Jews and that Paul changed
all that but I don't think Paul change
the biology
with these animals I don't know what to
say to these individual scriptural lies
well let me give you a couple of
thoughts doc first of all the
distinction between clean animals and
unclean animals goes back before the
Jews you'll remember that when God told
Noah to take the animals on the ark
everybody sings the song that they came
to buy - but if you read it in the Bible
it says the unclean animals came by -
the clean animals came by sevens so now
it was Noah Jewish because everybody the
world's related to Noah today right the
whole world was repopulated by Noah and
his family so God even told Noah there's
a distinction the daughter what's that
in law that's right and so everybody's
related to Noah so if God made a
distinction between clean and unclean
for Noah then well you would think that
it still applies today you know there's
another verse you can read in Acts
chapter 10 where when Peter has this
vision and this sheet full of unclean
animals comes down from heaven God says
arise kill and eat Peter says not so
Lord I've never eaten anything common or
unclean now this is three-and-a-half
years after Christ has died Peter still
says we've never eaten anything unclean
and he never does take anything from the
sheet later God shows him the vision is
because he should not call the Gentiles
unclean and Peter says God has shown me
not to call any man common or unclean so
the vision had nothing to do with food
and yet Peter says I've never eaten
anything unclean and then you can read
in Isaiah chapter I think it's chapter
66 it says for with fire and with my
sword I will plead with all flesh and
the slain of the Lord will be many in
that day and it says those that sanctify
themselves and purify themselves behind
a tree eating the abomination the mouse
and the swine are going to be consumed
by the Lord when he comes so I mean here
it's saying that it's comparing eating
pigs with eating rats or mice and so you
know they are scavengers it in spite of
what some people say
a that you know you can just pray over
it now in the New Testament whatever you
pray over is clean that's really not a
very strong argument because no parent
would accept that from their child their
child cannot eat ice cream sundae for
breakfast and say but I'm just gonna
pray over it we all know that you can't
mock God you're gonna so what you reap
and whatever you eat there's
consequences for what you eat so the the
verses that Peter I'm sorry the verses
where Paul talks about praying over your
food it has nothing to do with pork pork
is never mentioned in those verses Paul
is talking about things sacrificed to
idols we don't have to worry about that
if you eat food in a Chinese restaurant
they got a Buddhist statue in the
restaurant doesn't mean your food is
gonna suddenly be spirit possessed
that's what Paul is talking about they
had those concerns back then so you're
on the right track you know I've got a
study I can send you doc for free and
it's called God's health plan and it's
got all the verses that you're looking
for in one study would you like a copy
of that sure I just dial this number
it's separate from this Studio number
it's an 800 number eight three five six
seven four seven eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven ask for
God's free health plan they'll send it
to you for free and nobody will pester
you thanks so much thanks for your
ministry
I appreciate thank you for your call and
that does free up another line if you'd
like to call on with your Bible question
one more time that number eight hundred
four six three seven two nine seven and
we're gonna be talking next to Toronto I
think is it laser there we go
Lisa I'm sorry hi you're on the air with
Bible answers live well thank you very
much and I'm so sorry I didn't talk down
your name I apologize okay I'm just call
me pastor Doug pastor Doug okay I'm
sorry hi yes I have a question pastor
Doug judges 9:23
my question is why would God send evil
spirit to in this case
Abimelech and the men of Shechem I'm
just wondering why would God send an
evil spirit well let me give you a story
in the Bible that explains how that
worked you may remember the book of Job
and the devil comes to the Lord and God
says have you considered I've got a
faithful servant named Joe and then he
says well the only reason job's faithful
is because you protect them anyway
there's this dialogue between the devil
and God and finally God says I'm gonna
let you test Joe and you're gonna find
out that that the reason for job's
faithfulness is not just because I'm
blessing them and so it says that the
Lord withdrew his protection from job
the devil came in there were limitations
on what the devil could do so when it
says God sent an evil spirit God didn't
send the devil to job any more than he
sent this evil spirit to Abimelech when
they rejected the Lord it's kind of like
when you reject light the automatic
consequence of rejecting light is
darkness comes in and so that's what
happened there is when they rejected the
light the darkness came in and does that
make sense it does make sense yeah so
yeah and there's a couple of other
places where it's you know the Pharaoh
and others it talks about them they
basically rejected God and then it
sounds like God hardened their heart but
it's just he was through his protection
and the devil comes in and that hardens
their heart because God doesn't tempt
anyone God is the author of every good
and perfect gift hey thank you very much
for your call we appreciate that and
with that we're gonna be talking to
Christy who's calling on line 4 but you
didn't know your on line four did you
Christy you're on the air with Bible
answers line hi thank you okay so I'm
going to ask about you guys were talking
earlier about the water into wine or
grape juice but I was wondering if you
can explain that a bit more how it would
be great to friend that wine because I
was always told that what made it such a
great miracle was that you know because
wine takes time to ferment and Jesus
could turn the water into wine right
away
I don't know that it would be any easier
to turn water into fermented grape juice
than it would be to turn it into
unfermented grape useless the very the
chemical difference between water and
grape juice is pretty astounding to just
speak the word and have that change so
yeah so the reason I don't believe that
it was fermented is the word wine in the
Bible you're not going to find the word
grape juice anywhere in the Bible it's
always called wine because the word wine
comes from an ancient word and it it
means the juice of the vine and it often
you have to read the vine you're like a
grape vine it's a similar root word and
you're not gonna find a place where it
says grape juice you do find places in
the Bible where it says you don't put
new wine then what is new wine new wines
grape juice right
you don't put new wine in old wine skins
because the new creatures will expand
and it bursts the skins and that's what
Jesus said Jesus compared his teaching
to new wine grape juice and it you can
read in Isaiah I think it's 65 it says
for as the new wine is in the cluster
well if it's still in the cluster it's
not fermented yet so in in the original
Greek here where it's talking about
their grape juice let me give you one
more verse that I think is proof for
that at the Last Supper
there was bread and wine correct mm-hmm
you know what Jesus said he said I will
not drink and this is in Matthew I will
not drink of the fruit of the vine again
until I drink it with you new in my
father's kingdom he specifically says
I'll drink it with you new meaning it'll
be new wine so old wine you can get old
wine all year long yeah fermented wine
you can get any time of year you can
only get grape juice back then they
didn't have Welch's grape juice you
could only get fresh grape juice around
the time of the harvest that's why at
the wedding they're amazed they say
you've saved the best for last
they didn't mean the hard stuff so now
I've got a book I wrote on that because
it's a really good question and the
people struggle with it and I'll send it
to you for free
and then you also just need to ask this
question Christy would Jesus after
people have been at a wedding feast for
several days would he make you know 30
gallons of booze I mean you look at what
happened look at what happens the
weddings after people have had too much
to drink I mean some weddings have
gotten off to a really bad start because
of the the drinking that happens and you
know typically wine if the Bible says
wine is a mocker strong drink is raging
whoever is deceived thereby is not wise
that's setting proverbs 22 but let me
send you the book called alcohol and the
Christian and all you got to do is call
this number they'll take down your
address I'll send it to you it's that
easy you can even read it online for
free right now at the amazing facts
website just type in Doug Batchelor
alcohol and the Christian you just
google that you'll find it and it'll
yeah all right appreciate your call oh
by the way if you want a copy to hold
it's eight hundred eight three five six
seven four seven and if you'd like to
call in with a question then just give
us a call that number again we have
another line open eight hundred four six
three seven two nine seven to call the
studio four six three seven two nine
seven I do see the other callers that
are waiting and we're gonna keep on
marching along here talking next to
Brian who's calling in and Brian you're
on the air with Bible answers live
tonight pastor I'm always doing much
better than I deserve
okay I'm listening to you on life talk
radio I'm calling from New Port Richey I
live right across from Jefferson
Minsky's synagogue and I go there Oh
bless your heart well I'm glad you're
tuning in you say hello to Jeff for me I
will okay my question is about the white
horse and revelation I know that's some
assembling but what is it what is it
speaking of the sword in his mouth is
the Word of God
okay but there's no animals and in
heaven so what does that white horse
mean that he's coming back on well
that's right now you you're correct
most of the animals that you find in
Revelation are symbols in Revelation 4
talks about a lamb that was slain now
who do you suppose that lamb represents
that would be Jesus then in Revelation
chapter 12 it talks about
dragon chasing after a woman who do you
think the dragon represents that would
be the same state when elijah went up to
heaven it says there were chariots and
horses of fire and I used to think
they're angels ride horses when they
pick someone up God is using terms that
we can understand
so I princess used to often mount they'd
ride on horses they were high it was
exalted it represented power represented
speed because horses could go much
faster than a man could run and so Jesus
is pictured coming as a conquering king
in the white horse white is a symbol of
purity
that's why brides typically wear white
so that white horse is symbolizing the
majesty the purity the speed the power
of Christ's return okay I wasn't sure
people were arguing with me they take
everything literally yeah I know you the
revelation is full of symbols yeah
question could you tell me I think it's
in Matthew where you see a face you can
move mountains exactly what that means I
believe it's something taking the
problems out of your life so I'm not
100% sure well you're right and the
biggest problem in our life is sin right
correct
and Jesus said if you got faith you can
say in to this mountain be plucked up
and cast into the sea and it will be
done praying to move Mount Everest yeah
God gives us bulldozers for that but
there's another verse in the Bible and I
just read it I think it's in oh and
maybe in Micah where it says he takes
our sins and cast them into the depths
of the sea correct so he tells us that
this mountain of sin is what he wants to
cast into the depths of the sea so that
that mountain is a symbol for the
burdens whatever the problems you have
in life okay thank you Pastor Doug and
I'll tell next week when I go to go to
the synagogue Doug said all right here I
sure appreciate that thanks so much
Brian we appreciate your phone call
friends that opens up another line and
we're gonna get started on another call
though we might have to take a break
before a complete with it all right
we're gonna go to talk with Christina
Christina you're on the air with Bible
answers live hi yeah we'll get started
and then we may need to take a break and
come back to you okay
not a problem my question is from
Matthew 5 verse 20 I was lying - no
actually what did Christ seen by being
more righteous than the Pharisees that
means if we're more righteous than the
Pharisees we can get into heaven
well the way Jesus said it it would mean
yes but he's not talking about the
legalistic righteousness when Christ
said except your righteousness exceeds
the righteousness of the Pharisees he's
saying you need a higher quality of
righteousness theirs was a righteousness
that was all outward display Christ said
you need a righteousness that's based on
a transformed heart so he's not saying
that we needed to be more legalistic
than the Pharisees he's saying we need a
higher caliber of righteousness now go
ahead and palm to that thought for just
a moment Christi we're going to be
taking a break this is out what they
call a heartbreak at the halfway through
the program some of our other affiliates
to do station idea right now
and gives us a chance to get a drink of
water we'll come back we do have other
lines open if you have a Bible question
for tonight
best half of the program is yet to come
800 God says that's 800 for 6 3 7 to 97
and also so much of what we offer is
that amazing facts dot o-r-g we're
coming right back
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
life's a curious thing I mean just when
things seem under control
wham you're hit with something new your
marriage is good
suddenly it's on the brink of divorce
the jobs great and then it's gone and
so's your life savings you feel healthy
Daniel doctor gives the bad news what's
coming next you could look to the stars
but they don't have the answers but this
does the prophecy Study Bible by amazing
facts
this Bible special its 27 personal study
guides lead you on a life-changing
journey through God's Word to discover
real answers to life's questions from
health and relationships to family and
the future the hopes in here get your
amazing facts prophecy Study Bible today
by calling
[Music]
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7
p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific time to receive
any of the Bible resources mentioned in
this evening's program call
[Music]
welcome back listening friends this is
Bible answers live if you've joined
along the way it is a live international
interactive Bible study and you are
invited to the table if you'd like to
call in with a Bible question we still
have some lines open 804 6 3 7 2 9 7
that's 804 637 297 and my name is Doug
Batchelor pastor Ross has the night off
tonight we're gonna go back to a caller
we left hanging Kristina was asking a
question about Matthew 5:20 and where
Jesus said unless your righteousness
exceeds the righteousness of the scribe
and the Pharisees you will by no means
enter the kingdom of heaven christena
you were back did that beginning of an
answer help you it did but I guess I
thought a follow-up question would be
the CSIs expounds the see expand on this
higher caliber of righteousness anywhere
else in the gospel yeah a matter of fact
it's in the context of what he's saying
if you go to the next verse he said you
have heard it said by them of old you
shall not murder
all right well the scribes and Pharisees
taught that and whoever murders is in
danger of judgment but I say if you're
angry with your brother without a cause
you're in danger of the judgment so
jesus said it's not just the action of
murder it's even the attitude of murder
and he goes on and he says it's not just
committing adultery it's thinking it in
your heart it's a higher caliber it's
not just the outward action it's the
inward attitude so Christ was saying
your righteousness has to be better now
I don't know what version of the Bible
you might be looking at but if you look
at Matthew 5:20 you'll notice the word
the righteousness does not appear it's
it's italicized which means it's added
by the translators so way this
originally reads is for I say to you
that unless your righteousness exceeds
the scribes and Pharisees you will by no
means enter the kingdom of heaven so
he's talking really about a better kind
of righteousness and they by the way the
scribes and Pharisees we're not truly
righteous because he said you're
devouring Widow houses and you're making
long prayers that's not righteous
so then I can obtain this righteousness
on my own
no all true righteousness comes by faith
in accepting the gift of Christ's
righteousness which is better than the
scribes and Pharisees and it comes to
you
the righteousness of Jesus comes to you
two ways first you accept it by faith
through prayer that's called
justification then as you follow him he
cleanses your life and you begin to walk
in a newness of life and you begin to
practice a different kind of life where
the bible does it say that we receive
Christ's righteousness yes well through
faith well you can look at Galatians
2:20 you can look at Romans chapter 6
you read just Romans chapter 6 there
matter of fact Romans chapter 8 Romans
has quite a bit about the righteousness
of Christ and in Galatians 2:20 Paul
said it's not either live with Christ
that lives in me and so when we come to
the Lord and we come in faith and say
lord please forgive our sins and we
thank you that you died for our sins he
takes our badness he gives us his
goodness or his righteousness his good
his right living have you done that
before have you asked him here in Nome
Alaska we have a prison ministry and
this was a question of our residents had
acts and so we didn't have all the
firsts to give them so I appreciate you
oh good well I tell you what yeah we
have a free book we'll be happy to send
you and you can download that housing
all the verses because I can't you know
in three minutes give you all the verses
on the righteousness that Jesus offers
us but if if you ask for the book three
steps to heaven you can download that
for free off the amazing facts website
or we'll send you a copy even way up to
Nome Alaska though it may take a few
days to get there and and yeah I give
greetings to our friends in prison you
tell them pastor Doug says hello
thank you all right thank you Christina
thanks for your patience all right with
that we're gonna talk to Samuel has been
waiting patiently Samuel you're on the
air with Bible answers live Conrad are
be uh you're on the air hi you know
sometimes we did the caller ID up here
and I'm not sure what the name is or
what the caller ideas and your your
question tonight good evening evening I
think you call for the past I'm calling
to gain wisdom of what God in the Bible
says about divorce I'm a separated
family and I lost my family two years
ago and I've been having a hard time
dealing with it mentally huh there's a
lot of anger there's a lot of percent
resentment and I'm trying to why my dog
just started by that's time you're
asking a spiritual question probably
yeah I've been dealing with the
resentment I've been doing what's bad
thoughts and trying to end it's very
cumbersome and wears down on me I've had
a lot of things go wrong since the
separation of my family I reached the
point where what the Bible has to say
yeah well I tell you what let me Conrad
we're getting a lot of background noise
here let me see if I can address some of
your question about what the Bible has
to say oh you know first of all
obviously one of the most traumatic
things a person can go through is a
divorce and I've had some friends that
say death is sometimes easier dealing
with the death in the family of in
divorce and because you know you need to
continue to interact especially if
there's children involved and there's a
lot of pain there can be resentment
there can be anger there can be regret
over mistakes usually mistakes on both
sides the first thing to do is to just
completely present yourself to the Lord
and say
and I'm broken the marriage is broken
and I need a new beginning
kind of like that Samaritan woman when
she met Jesus she had been through five
husbands
sounds like a Hollywood film star and
she was living with a guy she wasn't
married to and yet Jesus came to her and
revealed he was the Messiah
so you just completely surrender if
you've done that before you surrender a
new to the Lord and you start rebuilding
your life there's gonna be you know even
though God forgives us there's always
gonna be some kind of scars you pray
that God will give you healing you've
been hit by a tidal wave whenever you go
through a large
grief it could be a death it could be a
divorce some traumatic experience it
could be a terrible health crisis you
feel like you're hit by a tidal wave but
as time goes by and God heals the waves
get further apart and the waves get
smaller and so you will begin to heal
from this and rebuild your life yeah you
sound like you still a relatively young
man I have a book I'd like to send you I
wrote for this particular reason it'd be
great for you to get some good counsel
from a pastor get be part of a recovery
and group dealing with divorce recovery
and the book I wrote I'll send you a
copy it's called marriage divorce and
remarriage and just call the resource
line this is a different phone number
than the studio eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven eight
hundred eight thirty five six seven four
seven and we'll be happy to send you a
free copy
thank you very much didn't now do that
I'm gonna bring your volume back up did
that help your question at all oh yes
did I seem to be there are times where I
feel that I have all the answers and I
have it under control and then a thought
would come to me or something you know I
thought of something that has happened
and I seem to slip right back into the
same mindset as before now you just you
gave the key right there you
you'll catch yourself thinking about
these triggers that bring the
frustration and the anger ask the Lord
to just guide your thinking and think on
those things as Paul says that are just
I think this is Philippians just and
Noble and pure and holy and good yeah
Philippians 4:8 and when you pray that
prayer and you catch some of these old
memories coming in your mind that just
start to trigger the unhappy feelings
say all right Lord I'm not going to
dwell on that now those thoughts will
come but you can reject them and it'll
get easier
hey thank you very much and we'll be
praying for you we know there's a lot of
people out there that are struggling
that have maybe been through a divorce
or some of these trials and that's very
difficult and it happens to Christians
too all right we're going to talk next -
is this Pamela hi how are you Pamela
thanks for calling in I'm doing
wonderful gives you a message or tell
you something well yeah there's a
variety of ways the first and foremost
you know God will speak to you through
his word when you read the word you'll
you'll say oh wow God is telling me in
his word do this or don't do that but
not every decision in life comes via the
Bible and so sometimes God guides us
through Christian counsel if you've got
several friends that maybe there are you
know they got a good relationship with
the Lord and they're counseling you in a
certain direction he may be trying to
speak to you through them sometimes
Providence will tell you when I say
Providence things happen and God will
start closing the door because he's
nudging you in another direction or he
may open a new door and he's nudging you
towards this new opportunity and so you
look at things happening around you God
does speak to us through our spirit but
that's not always the safest guide
because sometimes we get our own desires
mixed up with the Holy Spirit and we
can't tell the difference and so that
can be a little bit dicey saying always
God's Spirit telling me this or is it my
own desires or just you know even the
devil can give you feelings I mean so
the feelings are not the safest guide
and yeah and then you know you just pray
for providential indicators and spend
time in prayer because if you commit
your way to the Lord he will direct your
path yeah absolutely now Pamela I've got
a book I'll send you for free it's
called how to know the will of God if
you call the resource line I'll be happy
to send that to you that's eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
and tell them you're listening the Bible
answer is live and you've been offered
the book how to know the will of God
that sounds like it's up the alley of
your question alright preciate your call
and let's see we've got a few people
have been waiting patiently gonna talk
next to Christie Chrissy you're on the
air with Bible answers live hi how you
doing suss today doing great thank you
for calling I have a group of us have
been having discussion and dealing with
demon-possession
with young lady and so we know that in
Matthew when Jesus encountered the
demon-possessed man he rebuked them and
so our question is in dealing with such
a thing we know that without prayer you
can't deal with such because Christ said
that we are not dealing with anything of
this realm and we have actually
witnessed the demonic spirits in this
lady where in scripture can we find or
is there in dealing with such well of
course you have mark chapter five where
Jesus cast a legion of demons out of one
man that's the most intense example in
the Bible because this man's got you
know he's running around naked he's
covered with chains he's living among
tombs and pigs and he's a perfect
example of an absolutely lost individual
and Jesus sets him
and then sends him out preaching so it's
a it's the most radical conversion in
the Bible and when the disciples one
time came to Jesus and they said why
couldn't we cast out this demon
it's the same chapter actually a little
later on he said this kind does not come
out except prayer and fasting and so
there might be difficult cases where you
may want to take some time and fast and
pray for a brother and sister that's
struggling with you know what may be
demonic possession
some people have genuine mental problems
and they just need healing or sometimes
they may need a man may need a chemical
and it's missing that it is true a
person can be low on b12 or something
else and actually it'll affect them
mentally but so a prayer be a good
witness claim the promises of God I
don't recommend that Christian groups
get involved in like exorcisms you'll
notice in the Bible that the Apostles
never went looking for demon-possessed
people yeah it they always it seems like
they just showed up and they had to deal
with Paul was out preaching and this
girl began to follow him and he cast the
devil out of her and Jesus was preaching
and this demon-possessed man came into
the synagogue but they never really went
out looking for him you know so I think
we ought to avoid it there's enough
there's enough demonic activity in the
world that we run into without looking
for it no I know it's mean yeah we were
actually told last week person that I'm
just using you and I mean it just brings
killed but just the how the outward
appearance just totally changed on this
person you know yeah and like even the
izing went darker when all of a sudden
it started vocalizing you know there
could be physiological changes if a
person is demon-possessed just as if a
person's filled with the spirit you know
the Bible says Moses face was shining
so you know I do have a sermon that if
you go to just YouTube type in Doug
Batchelor I hate to say this but I
pinned Doug Batchelor demons and you'll
see a sermon I did on dealing with
demonic possession
I think it's called dealing with demons
and evil spirits but he's got about
50,000 views so I deal with a bunch of
scriptures on that and there's a lot
more there than I can share with you in
just a moment or two but see if that
helps Christie and we do appreciate your
call and there is a Bible study we offer
if you want a free copy it's called did
God create a devil and I think you'll
find that very helpful it tell us about
the origin why do we have evil spirits
in the world and you can get that by
calling 808 three five six seven four
seven and thank you for your call gonna
talk next with Robert who's listening on
Bible answers live Robert you're on the
air good evening evening thank you for
waiting
no I'm problemo I have a couple
questions regarding Sabbath King one is
I am I hear a lot of people say that the
Sabbath was only meant for Israel all
right you want me to address that real
quick yeah all right the first mention
of the Sabbath is on the seventh day of
creation in Genesis chapter two you
can't really go back much further than
Genesis chapter 2 God blessed the day he
sanctified it he sets it aside way back
in the beginning and he did it for man
jesus said the Sabbath was made for man
I think the word there in Greek is
anthropos meaning mankind humanity so
the idea that the sabbath is just for
the Jews and that only Jews need a day
of worship and rest is really absurd
when you think about it it goes back to
the beginning and it even says in heaven
you can read the in Isaiah 66 it says
that from one Sabbath to another all
flesh will come and worship before him
in the new heaven and the new earth so
if you've got it all the way back there
in Genesis for Adam and Eve and if
you've got it of course in the
wilderness and you've got it with the
Apostles in Christ
and you have it in heaven why wouldn't
we need a day of worship and rest now
does that make sense yeah have you heard
before that the Sabbath wasn't really
kept until until the giving of the manna
kind of thing yeah I have heard that but
I I think I can show otherwise
for example the giving of the man is
chapter 16 Chris Ten Commandments don't
come until chapter 20 but when God does
rain the manna down from heaven in
chapter 16 of Jannah of Exodus the
people did not listen they went out
gathering on the Sabbath day and God
says how long will you refuse to keep my
Commandments and so God refers to the
Sabbath as a commandment before he even
gave the Ten Commandments and then if
you go to Genesis I think it's chapter
is a chapter street where the Pharaoh
said to Moses Moses meant were the
leaders of Israel and they started to
rest and the Pharaoh said you're causing
the people to Shabbat he said you're
making the people rest the original word
there is Sabbath and so even when Moses
first began the Exodus Odyssey he said
look you need to return to the Lord and
part of that was to come return back to
the commandments of God they've gotten
from Genesis and so yeah and even I and
I say I can't remember the verse it
might be 65 he says and the sons of the
stranger that joined themselves to the
Lord and keep his Sabbath meaning the
Gentiles so I think that cookie think
yeah that's it correct thank you isaiah
50:6 so I think there's a number of
examples in the Bible where the Sabbath
is not made for one race of people and
then you said you had a second part to
your question yeah Hosea chapter 2 verse
11 talks about God taking away the
Sabbath yeah not only in Hosea 2 but in
I think he also says it in Isaiah he
says away with your Sabbath's meaning
any of their holidays our feast that
they camped thinking they were earning
them their righteousness that God I mean
anyone thinking about it if you
Hosea I mean Jesus hasn't even born yet
so the idea that the Sabbats were done
during the time of Hosea oh what's the
reason for that God wasn't saying the
Sabbath was over with he was just saying
all of your religious festivals if
you're not doing it through faith in me
it's smoking my nose I think that's what
Isaiah calls it so he said you come and
you pray long prayers and you stretch
out your hands and and Jesus he he said
the same thing to the religious leaders
in his day he said you fast to be seen
of men you give to be seen of men you
pray to be seen of men now Jesus didn't
say there was anything wrong with giving
we got to keep giving nothing wrong with
fasting and nothing wrong with praying
but don't do it for selfish reasons same
thing with the Sabbath and Hosea so
you're doing it for carnal reasons does
that make sense don't so not that he
took away this I was he now why would
God take away the one commandment that
begins with the word remember see on the
commandment begins with the word
remember why would he say now that's the
only one I want you to forget I mean
nobody argues about the other nine
Commandments right now I can stand up in
any church in the country and and I've
done it and preached you know honor your
father and mother and everybody says
amen and I could say thou shalt not
covet and they look nervous but they'll
say Amen and you can say thou shalt not
commit adultery and they may look
nervous but they'll say Amen and you can
go through all ten commandments and
they'll say Amen and then you say
remember the Sabbath day people are ok
as long as you don't say you're supposed
to do it on the seventh day then they
get nervous and they saw we're not under
the law now we're under grace so that
always seemed a little bit strange hey
you know I got a study we're gonna go to
another call Robert but let me send you
our study on that and it's called the
when God said to remember we got a
special study guide on the Sabbath if
you call the resource line and that
number is 885 six seven four seven and
ask for the amazing fact study guide on
the Sabbath day
and there's a website that's become very
popular it's called Sabbath truth simply
Sabbath truth com Sabbath
org you just if you go to google and you
tribe it type in Sabbath truth it's got
everything about the Sabbath the history
it's a very popular site and it's
encouraging to thank you for your call
we're gonna talk next to Kenneth he's
been waiting patiently Kenneth you're on
the air with Bible answers live hi I
just want to say I appreciate the work
you do in the ministry and clarity that
you bring those scriptures well thank
you um my question is we're doing a
study in the book of Acts and there's a
reference to a multitude who came and
became believers and then were later
filled with the Holy Spirit now when a
person comes to Christ you know Christ
comes into their heart and lives within
their heart and then the work begins
isn't it the Holy Spirit that does the
work in your heart and so when it
references being filled with the Holy
Spirit is it possible for a believer to
not have the Holy Spirit and what was
the significance in Acts where the
multitude that came and became believers
were later filled with the Holy Spirit
yeah because the Spirit comes in
different degrees and the Bible even
uses that figure it talks about the Holy
Spirit and it uses the analogy of
farming that you can have a light rain
and you could have a ladder rain there
could be a heavy rain and at Pentecost
they were baptized that baptism is
immersion that's a downpour so when
you're just completely immersed they
were baptized with the Holy Spirit it's
the Holy Spirit that brings us to
conviction even before we're believers
the Holy Spirit convicts us of our sin
it's the Holy Spirit that will lead us
to you know come to Jesus the Holy
Spirit comforts but you see the Holy
Spirit coming in different waves an
example would be Acts chapter 2 the
disciples are baptized in the Holy
Spirit
well the Apostles are there that day
correct right you get to Acts chapter 4
it says and they prayed and the place
was filled
with the power of the Spirit and they
spoke the Word of God they were filled
with the spirit again in Acts chapter 4
and you see several times where it says
the Spirit of the Lord came on this
person or that person it wasn't that the
spirit had totally left them so that
God's Spirit is you know I think in me
and you right now but that's different
from being baptized in the Holy Spirit
just before Jesus comes does that make
sense Ken absolutely and I tell you
that's where I want to be living right
there is in the infilling of the Holy
Spirit well you and I both tell you what
I appreciate your question I've got a
book that I wrote on the Holy Spirit and
it's called the Holy Spirit the need the
Holy Spirit the need by Doug Batchelor
you call the resource line we'll send
you one of those it's a little sermon
book easy to read eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven for the
free offer and it's called the Holy
Spirit the need all right we're gonna
try and take at least one more call here
we've got let me see if I get this
Walter has been waiting patiently Walter
you're on the air we've got about a
minute can you hear me yes sir
I've been trying for years in answer to
this question okay every year we
celebrate Christ's birth you know the
cleanest Easterling sisters crying to
birth and celebrated this so why do we
do the opposite well Solomon is talking
about the vanity of life in that passage
and he's saying you know it's better to
go to the house of mourning than the
house of feasting because Olivia will
take it to heart and even Joe when he
was going through his sufferings he said
you know let the day of my birth when
someone told my father there's a
man-child let it be darkness because of
the suffering in life but at the same
time they're places in the Bible where
it talks about rejoicing at the news of
a birth happy is the man that has his
quiver full of children and so yeah the
birth of somebody is sort of a
bittersweet question hey listen dear
friends you can tell from the music if
we didn't get your call tonight I
apologize we started slow and it filled
up with calls give us a chance again
next week and go to the amazing facts
website you've been blessed let us know
and you can
keep us on the air god bless you thank
you for listening to today's broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
amazing facts began in 1965 with a God
inspired concept
hello this is Joe Cruz on the amazing
facts broadcast facts which affect you
each radio broadcast would begin with an
amazing fact from science nature or
history followed by a Bible message that
touched the hearts of listeners from
every walk of life the program was an
instant success and the ministry soon
began expanding to include Bible lessons
in 1986 amazing facts added the medium
of television to its growing outreach
efforts offering soul-winning
evangelistic messages for viewers around
the world
in 1994 pastor Doug Batchelor assumed
leadership of the ministry adding the
Bible answers live call-in radio program
and new ministry TV programs began
airing on multiple networks around the
world for 50 years the driving vision of
amazing facts has been the bold
proclamation of the everlasting gospel
and with a team of evangelists circling
the globe and thousands of men and women
being trained through the amazing facts
center of evangelism program Affco the
ministry is helping God's church see a
rich harvest of souls amazing facts
God's message our mission
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at WWF AG 0 RG and
sign up for our free Bible study course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at AF bookstore comm which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 website at amazing facts
o RG did you enjoy this program make
sure to tell your family and friends
tune in next time for more Bible answers
live honest and accurate answers to your
Bible questions
[Music]